I suspect that most of you don't realize
that we actually do impact endangered
species in ways that you may not even
think of it
this is a blue bottle
it's actually called blue blood
and probably everyone in this room has
benefited from this substance
it's harvested every year from horseshoe
crabs
four hundred thousand
crabs a year are harvested on the East
Coast
they're impaled in these factories where
one third of their blood is drained
and the reason that you've benefited
from this is because of that blue
protein
it is used for every injectable drug or
vaccine that you've ever had or anyone
you know to make them safe safe from the
impurities in the manufacturing process
that could come in from bacteria in the
water
that Lal substance is referred to is the
gold standard for drug manufacturing
today and it's used with not only drugs
and vaccines with every implanted device
and it's used even in veterinary
medicine
but here's where the horseshoe crab
lives
this species comes in
once a year on the high tides of Mayan
June to spawn and it spawns in the
thousands of eggs every year
and it provides not only for the
proliferation of its species but also as
sustenance for wild birds and a whole
ecosystem
and these wild birds in particular this
is the Red Knot they migrate all the way
from the tip of South America all the
way to the Arctic Circle and they make
one pit stop in Delaware Bay to refuel
on the eggs of the horseshoe crab now
these species are being listed they're
endangered they're not making it to the
Arctic Circle and when they're making it
to the Arctic Circle those that do are
so thin and underfed that they usually
are not breeding
this is a multi-continent ecological
problem
and it's something that is done for the
welfare of humanity
that's why it's so linked to everything
that we do
but it doesn't have to be that way
and that's where synthetic biology comes
in
scientists back in 1995 at the
University of Singapore Dr Ling and Dr
Ho actually identified that unique
protein in the horseshoe crab that they
make the Lal
substance from and that unique protein
was synthesized and has been created
what was called the recombinant factor C
that RFC has languished on the market
because of corporate greed
because there's so much money in the
blood of the horseshoe crab
and it's also because of bureaucratic
inertia and Regulatory inertia we've
been advocating for the pharmaceutical
companies to do something to adopt this
synthetic alternative to force the
regulatory authorities to do something
we and other conservation groups have
organized a coalition and we've sent
letters Ad nauseam but one really bold
scientist from Eli Lilly has changed the
whole dynamic
I I'm a murderer so I have a unique
perspective in that I can see the impact
of the horseshoe crab not only because
of the horseshoe crab itself but the the
species that rely on yet including birds
and turtles and sport fish and all you
know anything that's in the ecosystem
that it's impacted
and so we were aware at Lily that there
was an alternative to the to the Lal
test reagent we generated the data but
it took a lot of alignment internally
and then externally we had to convince
the FDA and other health authorities
around the world but we did that with
our data and we convinced them
we drew a line in the sand of 2016 and
we said that all new drugs that are
manufactured athlete
we would apply the common factor C to
them and so our first product was
approved in 2018 and that was a
milestone because that was at first an
industry approval of any medicine using
RFC for release and then we subsequently
had six additional product approvals
since then including our three covid-19
antibodies our goal when we set out was
to convert all eight of our
manufacturing quality control Labs at
the time to RFC and we've done that and
it's been Industries following we have
we have our peers sanofi and Pfizer and
roshinen Tech have all come out and made
statements similar to what we've done
which is that little converter water
testing and all of our new product
testing so there's definitely a movement
towards more sustainable endotoxin
testing
one footnote on that
America truly is lagging behind on this
adoption Europe Japan Korea have all
adopted the standards to approve RFC in
testing it's really our country that is
the problem the horseshoe crab has been
around for 445 million years it survived
five mass extinctions and it's not until
the last 100 years that humans have
threatened it with Extinction I believe
that when humans
cause the problem we have a
responsibility to create Solutions
if we look back Ten Thousand Years the
world was a very different planet
there was much more biodiversity but
because of our human presence we have
actually closed out so many of those
opportunities to let those species
thrive
we're at a point in time where I think
that by combining both conventional
approaches to conservation along with
new technologies and biotechnology that
we can actually Envision a much richer
more bio-abundant future it takes time
to make changes happen in conservation
the conservationists that we work with
in some cases they have to work at the
pace of nature
but the truth is they all live in the
long now
and we're all looking to see how we can
build a better future
foreign